hello everyone I used and hope you guys
are having a wonderful day today here
with another video and in today's video
I will be building on a method that I
recently uploaded in the spin flex video
I showed you guys a method that you
could get 85k crafting and magic XP per
hour while also profiting close to 500k
now since then bowstring prices have
gone down but this method is more than
promising so I had this method pointed
out to me in the comments of that video
and that is what I want to go over right
now so as you guys can see on screen
right now this is a reddit post by pi
romantico and basically as is nice
little layout showing people how to do
one of the best training methods in old
school runescape as far as I'm concerned
with magic and just overall efficiency
it's something that's really profitable
more so profitable then he says in his
picture and on top of that bowstring
prices are looking pretty promising to
go up in the future considering with
mobile and whatnot there going to be
more and more unstrung bows within the
game so they'll be sold for lower prices
and thus the bowstring prices will need
to go up to accommodate the longbow
prices because those are pretty much
bound by an out price with that said
though the picture is a lot to take in
so I'm gonna go ahead and show you guys
what all you're going to need basically
you are gonna need three spells unlocked
on the lunar spell book and that is in
the form of spin flex magic and view and
plank make now I guess you don't
necessarily need them all but that's
what we're going to be doing for this
method so that does require 86 magic and
lunar diplomacy to be done as far as
what you're going to want your inventory
and gear set to look like what I'd
recommend doing is having a Toma fire
now Toma fire you don't actually use any
of the pages in it but just have one
page in it and that will act as infinite
fire rinse which will save you some
inventory space that you will need to
have saved on top of that dust battle
staff is going to be what you're going
to want to go for here and having a rune
pouch would be really nice because it
allows you to steward nature's waters
and Astral's all of which you will be
using while doing this method now as you
guys can see we're pretty tight on space
in regards to having two rooms being
used here another one here and three in
here so it is pretty necessary to have
all of this if not you're going to be
using up inventory space that's going to
definitely hinder your trip so as far as
its concerned with actually trying to do
this method and doing it somewhat
efficiently I'm gonna go ahead and now
and give you guys some little tips so
one thing I would say is get out your
room pouch and your coins and have no
placeholders in your bank because you
want to go ahead and be able to deposit
inventory without having these go in
your bank it'll be quite annoying if you
actually had that happen and it saves
you a click from having to deposit all
over here as far as what you will be
withdraw
you'll be withdrawing 20 flex to go
ahead and have your set X as 20 and then
just withdraw 10 or more of the mahogany
logs from there what you're gonna want
to go ahead and do I personally use f
keys the ones that I have set right now
is escape to close the bank obviously f2
for inventory and f4 for magic you can
have it set up however you please but it
is kind of nice to be able to go between
these because sometimes you do miss
click it with the plank make like see
right there obviously didn't click
anything and sometimes it is kind of
annoying to get back there if you aren't
having your hands on the F keys so the
way that you want to go about it is to
start an inventory off just go ahead and
spin flex magic in view and then use
plank make use plank make twice and then
go ahead and do spin flax again do plank
make twice again and then do spin flex
as well so basically every inventory
you're going to want to magic and view
right away it really doesn't matter when
you do it necessarily it's just kind of
nice to get in the vibe of it whenever
it is the beginning of an inventory so
from there make sure that you have a
spot in your bank from mahogany planks
and bow strings as well but deposit all
and start up another inventory so it
definitely can do this a little faster
I'll go ahead and try to do one now at
least somewhat fast so there we have
spin flags magic in view and plank plank
spin flax plank
oh god miss clicks plank spin Flags
plank flank and spin flax again and
there you go that's your average
inventory I think that's about yeah it
is 960 magic XP and on top of that you
get 300 crafting XP so definitely really
nice and it is insane amount of XP so
with that said I'm gonna go ahead now
and test what I can get hourly and I'll
be back to you guys here in a second one
thing I would like to add is the overall
cost and profit per inventory so this is
going to be all of the runes and items
that you'll use in an inventory on top
of that you will be using some cash in
the form of actually being able to make
these mahogany flanks so you'll be using
6.3 K cash for inventory and that comes
out to about 14.5 K overall so with that
said as far as what you can expect to
actually make back from this you get
back six muga new planks in twenty beau
shrinks coming out of at a total of
fifteen point eight K so doing some math
that is a 1.3 k profit per inventory and
now I'm gonna go ahead and get on into
the XP rates per hour so after some
testing here is what I was able to find
basically as far as magic XP per hour is
concerned I was able to get 215 K per
hour now that is absolutely insane
compare this to just regularly spinning
flags she'll be getting 85
okay granted you'll be getting some more
crafting XP overall with this method I
was able to get 70 K crafting XP per
hour while with just spin flags alone
you would get closer to 85 K obviously a
trade-off of 15 K and on top of that as
far as cash per hour
you should be averaging around or at
least I was able to average around 230
inventories per hour and basically the
way that shakes out is it's about a 300
kg P Brower method obviously pretty good
considering you're able to get this much
XP in both magic and crafting and on top
of that profit granted click intensive
obviously but when you compare that
overall this is definitely an insane
method overall as far as efficiency goes
and the fact that it's profitable as
well as impressive an ounce so the main
reason that this is all able to really
work is for some reason there is no tick
variation and there is no limits as far
as how many actions you can do on the
lunar spell book now one thing I did
notice if you do plank make and then you
do some spin flex it times out kind of
weird and you sometimes can't do it at
the same time it happened to tick later
but as far as just doing stuff like this
you just go spin flex magic in view and
then a log like look at that drop that
is insane but obviously a great method
and hopefully you guys can make some use
of it it's something that's going to be
around for a while considering all of
the prices of the stuff is relatively
set in stone so you shouldn't have to
worry too much about any variation as
far as price is concerned and this will
be a great method as far as anyone that
wants to train magic or crafting and
gain a little bit of GP going forward so
hopefully you guys enjoyed if you did
make sure to leave a like if there's
anything you guys want to tell me feel
free to leave it in the comments down
below on top of that if you guys enjoy
my content make sure to subscribe to my
channel but with that said hopefully you
guys have a wonderful day and peace